The night sky seems peaceful and orderly, but in reality,
stars are careening through the galaxy at speeds of hundreds of thousands of
kilometers per hour, not bound by static formations,
but changing neighborhoods constantly. Fortunately, space is big.
And so the stars of the Milky way are very unlikely to hit us. Unfortunately,
they don't have to hit anything to make us have a ready bad time on earth.
And there are already stars starting to get very close.
[Inaudible].
To understand how dangerous stars are to us. We need to talk about gravity.
Gravity attracts every piece of master to every other piece of matter.
In the universe, you are attracted by an atom,
a million light years away and vice versa.
Luckily this force gets weaker over distance,
and it also depends on how massive something is.
So things that are close and are very massive,
are more attractive winning the cosmic tug of war this way,
massive things to find how smaller things behave around them.
The sun makes up 99.7, 5% of all the mass and the solar system.
And so it shapes the behavior and orbits of everything else in it.
Billions of years ago, after the son was born,
the soda system was a chaotic and dangerous place.
As the planets were formed through countless little pieces that collided
constantly, but over the eons, a stable balance emerged today.
Most planets and asteroids have settled into safe and predictable August.
We have the inner and outer planets, the asteroid and Kuyper belt.
And at the edge, the Oort cloud,
a giant sphere of comets orbiting slowly in cold storage.
We really don't want this balance to be disturbed.
If another star came too close to us,
it's gravity would put on everything in the soda system, like a spoiled toddler,
messing up the present holder of the planets and asteroids and comets.
This isn't some imaginary danger. Some 70,000 years ago,
a red dwarf Brown dwarf binary system passed through the all cloud and mess
things up. It might even have sent a deadly onslaught of asteroids our way,
but it could take 2 million years until those visitors from the Oort cloud
arrive in the inner solar system.
But there's a much bigger problem on the horizon. Glazer seven 10,
a red Wolf with about half the mass of the sun is currently headed toward the
solar system in about a million years.
It'll pass through the old cloud and become the brightest star in the night sky,
a close fly by like this would unfold over hundreds of thousands of years
disrupting the orbits of millions of objects in the order cloud considerably.
If we're unlucky, it will trigger a new period of planetary bombardment.
Similar to the early solar system.
The night sky could be filled with comments and asteroids raining down on the
inner solar system.
The larger ones could cause dinosaur level mass extinctions and would be bad for
the stock market, but it could get much worse.
The galaxy is an intense place and stars get close to each other regularly.
So it is possible that a star could come much closer and not just pass us,
but fly directly through the inner solar system.
This would be very bad in the extreme,
the chance of another star colliding with a sun is astronomically unlikely,
but that isn't what we're worried about.
If another star were to pass by about as close as the earth is from the sun,
it could easily object the earth from the solar system.
The odds of such an event are estimated to be around one in 100,000 in the next
5 billion India is small, but not absurdly.
So as we discussed in another video,
there seemed to be billions of rogue planets doing their own thing and the
galaxy, and this is one way to make them.
So if this were to happen with an average red dwarf, what would happen?
Kicking earth out of the solar system, as the star enters the soda system,
a small orange dot appears in the sky that grows bigger and bigger for months
eventually becoming visible during the day,
it would get bigger and much brighter than the moon too bright to look at
directly. The night sky would be filled with an airy red glow.
After a few months, it would start striking again.
But so would the sun over a few years,
the sun slowly grows smaller in the sky and with it warmth and light start to
dissipate all around the world. As the days turned dark,
the final winter of humanity would begin.
The polar ice caps begin to grow and spread while clouds, shrivel,
and die forests, freeze and animals die in droves.
As the earth passes, the orbit of Mars,
the average surface temperature has plummeted to near minus 50 degrees.
Celsius from space earth begins to look like an icy moon.
The blue green surface becoming the pale gray white of death.
As global infrastructure breaks down, people huddled together,
indoors burning what they can for warmth.
As the temperature continues to drop counting the days until there'll be out of
food, which no longer grows.
Everybody living at the surface is living on borrowed time.
By the time earth reaches,
Jupiter's always surface temperatures sink to minus 150 degrees Celsius
lower than the coldest ever recorded. Temperatures in Antarctica,
needless to say by now,
almost everyone is dead without the energy from sunlight to
evaporate, water clouds, don't form, and the water cycle stops.
The polar ice caps eventually touch to the equator and the oceans become covered
in a thick layer of ice as more and more of its heats leaks out more water
freezes onto the bottom of the ice sheet.
The concentration of salt in the deep ocean grows poisoning.
Most animals that survived here, although hydrothermal vents,
communities of extremophiles that might adapt to even to these circumstances
deep below the surface,
some bacteria would not notice much of any of this as they're still kept warm by
the radioactive decay of elements in the Earth's core.
As the earth reaches the orbit of Pluto and the Kuiper belt,
the sun is still the brightest star in the sky,
but it's one among many with stars now visible during the day,
the temperature is now barely 40 degrees Celsius above absolute zero below the
freezing temperature of the gases in the atmosphere.
A weird spectacle enjoyed by no one,
unfortunately unfolds as the atmosphere turns into nitrogen and then oxygen
snow. Over a few years,
it's deposited into an IC 10 meter thick sheet all over the planet surface with
only a thin whisper of gas remaining,
the frozen corpuses of flora and fauna, uh,
buried beneath them as earth leaves the soda system.
It becomes a road Panisse traveling alone through the dark
lifeless and in solitude. But weirdly enough,
there is hope humanity would not be surprised by this potential extinction
event. We'd notice it thousands of years in advance.
There's not a lot we could do to stop a star,
but we could prepare most of us would perish,
but a few million cuts survive in huge artificial complex is powered by
geothermal and nuclear energy, possibly even fusion.
If we can learn to use the ice around us for power here,
humanity might survive for hundreds of thousands of years.
At some point we would become used to our circumstances and new generations
would watch documentaries in disbelief about the time we had our own star and
could walk the surface of earth.
And at some point we might decide to look for another home.
If the earth were lucky enough to pass by another star with a habitable planet,
we could try to make a fresh start. The space flight,
oddly enough would become very easy without the atmosphere in the way.
So it's not unthinkable that the last survivors would leave earth behind and try
again on a new planet around a new star.
Maybe one day thousands of years later,
the descendants of humanity will tell legends about Earth's ancient past
stories of our lost home of a mysterious icy planet
floating alone and empty through the dark of space.
So basically the key to humanity's survival.
Letting about what we'll be dealing with. Well,
we'd better get cracking then our friends from brilliant.
Oh, the perfect coaches on the way to becoming more science savvy,
brilliant as a problem solving website and app that makes science accessible in
a practical way. While there's 60 interactive courses,
give you the tools to crack problems in maths, logic,
and engineering all by yourself. Instead of a classic lecture format,
brilliant uses storytelling code writing and hands-on problems to keep you
entertained and engaged this way.
A small daily challenge can build up to real longterm understanding of science
and achieving your STEM goals in a nutshell, brilliant surprises,
you and keeps you on your toes all while sneaking some knowledge into your head
without you're ready, noticing right up our Annie,
really to get a fresh perspective on science,
go to brilliant.org/nutshell and sign up for free.
And there's an extra perk for cuts cause out viewers,
the first 200 people to use the link, get 20% off that annual membership,
which lets you view all the daily problems in the archives and unlock every
course. Brilliant helps you and your day, a little smarter,
still the best preparation for the future. We can think of.
[Inaudible].